hi guys I'm Eric BOTS and now that Logan
has been out in Cedars for a little
while now my therapist says I can talk
about it without breaking down sobbing
oh I wanted to take a deeper look at the
film to explore all the reasons that
make it great now obviously Logan isn't
like most other superhero movies that
we've seen it's less about connecting to
the continuity of the other films and
setting up a bunch of Easter eggs
although there are a few fun references
and I'll point those out and if you want
an explanation of how Logan fits in with
the x-men I made another video about
that but in this video I'm going to go
through Logan and point out all the
other details that I found interesting
all the choices made by Hugh Jackman
James Mangold and the creative team to
make Logan unique to the genre of
superhero films and obviously spoiler
warning if you haven't seen Logan yet
but still clicks on a YouTube video
breaking down the film somehow that's on
me let's get started okay looking at
these opening images the first shot of
the film is Logan rising up in the frame
as the car Jack lifts his limo I love
this shot it's almost like Logan is
being dragged out of his drunken despair
for one last fight and when the thugs
shoot him in the chest the title of the
film appears as he struggles to get back
up and I think this is foreshadowing
where Logan will end up at the end of
the film bleeding out on the ground as
his powers fail him now this scene with
Logan pairing all these guys to pieces
it's already the most violent that we've
ever seen wolverine james mangold is
using this opening scene to set the tone
for the rest of the film like brace
yourself this wolverine is going to be
way more extreme than the version of the
character that you remember but also
kind of the version we always wanted now
bogans our rating was the decision made
early on in the process
mango wanted to be able to make a more
adult film where it seems could run
longer and be shot more poetically
without having to play for a younger
more attention deprived audience now
before I move on to the rest of the
movie I haven't forgotten about that
opening Deadpool scene that played
before the movie actually made another
video about that but if things seemed
missing from that video it's because we
made it before the fuller version of the
no good deed scene came out online and
that version had a few changes from the
original theatrical versions like Wade
is listening to a different song and
there's a Stan Lee cameo still you
should check out my other video because
I point out some Easter eggs and explain
how that old man in the sea synopsis
connects with the story of Logan anyway
back to Logan
how this limo has a digital display
showing Logan's license with the name
James pallet that's his birth name which
we saw in x-men origin but this modern
digital display is one of the only
instances of futuristic tech in this
whole movie the production designer said
that originally the limo was going to
have a touchscreen poker table in the
back but mangled ultimately scrapped it
because it would be too distracting they
felt that too many superhero movies
include anachronistic hologram and touch
display technology and they didn't want
Logan to look that flashy or futuristic
instead they shot Logan with limited CGI
spectacle making it more of a true
modern Western and Road film that
focused on the relationships between the
characters there were also a few clues
here that hints at the later reveal of
Whydah mutants are disappearing first
there's a radio call-in show where a
conspiracy nut job claims now the theory
is ignored but the caller in Sabine's
spot on Van der Rice actually was
dispensing an anti-mutant toxin into
consumer products also when the party
roads are chanting USA through the
sunroof check out what they're drinking
that looks like an energy drink similar
to the one that we see Laura drinking
from at the gas station later on the
production designer added this subtle
detail because he didn't want to
overwhelm us with the logistics of
Rice's painted high fructose corn syrup
being consumed by everyone just a few
little details to justify it enough for
people watching closely and yes there
are some connections to the comics other
people have already pointed out like
Logan's clothes look similar to his
apparent suggestible brain and Greenwood
Cemetery does show up a few times in the
Marvel comics and of course this whole
version the character is based loosely
on the old man Logan comics with Logan
as an old grizzled recluse on a violent
road trip but really of than that
this movie is nothing like that comic
which is super insane and stylized and
it contains a ton of Marvel property
characters that Fox doesn't have the
rights to the author of old man Logan
actually suggested early on that they
could try to adapt it swapping out Hulk
with blob and Hawkeye with Cyclops after
he like lost his eyewear and had to
cover his eyes the whole movie but
ultimately mangled and Jackman just went
in a different direction anyway moving
on to this scene with Logan and Donald
Pierce Boyd Holbrook's a part cybernetic
leader of the Reavers view
interesting things here one notice how
Pierce keeps referring the Logan and the
other former x-men like they're
celebrities saying he's a fan I actually
had a theory about why this movie plays
up the former celebrity status of the
x-men and why x-men comics exist in this
movie said I get into my other video now
it's kind of a stretch that has to do
with secret codes and x-men turned
comic-book artists but it's super
interesting so go check it out and
there's also a few other possible
references here Pierce says that they
found a few torn up guides with police
thinking it was either caused by Freddy
Krueger or a tiger one of which is
fictional and the other extinct but
those also seem like descriptions for
Wolverine and Sabretooth and Liev
Schreiber sleepers whose was going to
appear in this movie but they end up
going another way I'll talk about that
later and then there was my favorite
joke reference in this movie which I
brought up in the other video here says
to Logan I heard you was in Phoenix yay
was okay moving on to Logan's hideout at
this smelting Factory south of the
border now there's some interesting
history behind this mangles original
idea was to make Logan and Charles live
in an abandoned bourbon distillery in
Kentucky with Charles's room being an
old Bourbon tank but then men gold was
inspired by current events specifically
the refugee crisis and the issue that
the mexican-american border so they
moved the setting to El Paso and Patrick
Stewart said in an interview that this
plot point of border crossing became
even more relevant as time went on it
may just be a case of life catching up
with art because the movie was received
and the ideas were first being discussed
and the script in development before we
had found ourselves worldwide in the
situation that we are in with hundreds
and hundreds of dispossessed abandoned
people who just like the three principal
good characters in our movie are trying
to get to a border and cross it now at
this point the idea was to make Logan's
hideout and old oil refineries but the
production designer realized that that
would be too large and sprawling and
after research he found smelting
factories are smaller and more intimate
more like a home and then a location
scout showed him a photo in New Mexico
of a tipped-over water tower and that
and locked it in for him and I pointed
this out in trailer
but the interior of this water tank was
indeed intended to evoke cerebro mangled
liked how the holes look like a star
filled and the metal dome keeps
Charles's mind trapped inside a reversal
of how cerebro works and this scene
between Charles and Logan is a key
moment between the characters mangled
wanted a long rounded scene early on
depicting Logan as a domestic caretaker
and Charles as a plausibly senile old
man suffering from Alzheimer's who at
times doesn't recognize Logan and then
ends up saying bitter cruel things to
him Patrick Stewart said that he lost 21
pounds for the role and that's actually
Hugh Jackman carrying him in the scene
and the scene kind of implied some
answers about this movie's timeline like
Charles references the Statue of Liberty
incident and Logan's cage riding past
both from the first x-men film but
really I think these are just meant to
remind us of the film that we first saw
these two men together and how far
they've come also notice when Logan says
we both could you sleep sleep I think
that's a subtle foreshadowing of what's
to come for these two both the
characters and the actors who make their
final appearances in the role then in
Logan's bedroom we get some other
references to past Wolverine films with
his katana sword from his adventures in
Japan and the Wolverine also his dog
tags which we saw in x-men origins so
again even a lot of these events were
supposed to be erased or rewritten and
date the future path this movie really
doesn't want us to think too hard about
the timeline but I want to talk about
the look of Logan here this movie's
director of photography was John
Matheson he's the same guy who shot
x-men first class Matheson explained
that unlike first class nothing in Logan
is meant to look attractive or
glamorized everything is gritty and
dirty and sun damage and the way he
achieved that was by using just one
overhead light to look like the Sun so
that the light streaks down the actors
face and hollows out the eyes mixed the
scars stand out and make Logan beard
looks ugly and unshaved and I think this
lighting effect does a lot to accentuate
Logan's age and exhaustion throughout
the film and the next name makes Logan's
deterioration even clearer with Caliban
calling out his health problems and his
failing vision which is why we see Logan
wearing new glasses in the next scene
Caliban also returns Logan's adamantium
bullet which we also saw an x-men origin
now I'm talking about Cal
man in my trailer breakdowns but I like
the details they added with this Stephen
Merchant version for one his skin burns
when it's exposed to sunlight making
that Nosferatu joke he made earlier
literal also his mutant tracking ability
seems to come with a heightened sense of
smell like he can smell the adamantium
in the bullet and the fact that Logan's
body is being poisoned from the inside
this sniff gesture gives a little tech
Atilla t-to Caliban powers like we can
kind of see it in action as opposed to
some abstract mental process okay moving
on when Logan runs into Gabriella and
Laura the motel we get another quick
clue about the mutant mystery with this
newspaper headline
lack of mutant birth stuff researchers
is there something in the water um yes
there is don't drink it in fact don't
eat drink or consume anything thanks
great and I actually think that idea of
the water supply being tainted is
another concept taken directly from
real-life headlines with dangerous
traces of lead found in the drinking
water in Flint Michigan now they
discovered that in 2014 but many
residents had been cleaning that for
years with it just being brushed off as
paranoia much like this theory and Logan
it
okay moving back to the hideout where
Laura ends up with Logan and Charles and
Pierce shows up with rest of the Reavers
and here's where this hardy violent
movie just codes berserk it turns out
Laura is holding a severed Reaper head
in the shot and even though I spotted
that in the trailer it's still super
intense to see her just like bowl it
over like it's nothing and real quick I
like how right as Laura springs into
action we get this close-up of Charles
smiling pretty much reflecting what
we're all feeling in this moment like Oh
11 year old girl is murdering a bunch of
people and getting her food this is
great really I think Charles is just
happy to see Laura act like Logan does
he notices her claws her rage and here's
Pierce say that she healed for Charles
this is the first sign of hope that the
excellent legacy may move on with a new
generation we also see Laura's foot claw
which is now x-23 was introduced in the
animated series in the comics later
Charles explains that the two sets of
claws mirror the lioness which uses its
front claws for hunting and back clods
defensively and that's exactly what Bora
does here using her hands to attack and
her foot claw only when she's being held
down now James Mangold mentioned a few
movies that used as inspiration for
Logan one of which was the gauntlet
that's where Clint Eastwood have to
skort a woman from Vegas the Phoenix on
the run from some crooked cops and this
case in the limo feels a lot like the
chase scenes from that movie Eastwood
was actually an inspiration for both the
concept art for Logan and Jacqueline's
performance mangled also said that he
drew from movies like Paper Moon and
Little Miss Sunshine which are both road
movies featuring young girls also the
production designer said that they had
to build three different versions of
this limo one for exterior shots like it
gets shot up with bullets one for
interior shots and then a third one that
could go 100 miles an hour in the desert
with insane suspension that's why in
some shots the car looks merely torn to
pieces but then it could still move
powerfully over desert terrain and then
when Logan and charles watch the video
on Gabriella's phone we begin to get
some answers on Laura's back story along
with the other mutants and we get a
quick shot of Wolverines DNA which is
the same DNA that we saw being taken
from the Weapon X facility in the
post-credits scene after x-men
apocalypse okay moving on to this gas
station scene which we saw in the
trailer and a lot of people are
wondering why Laura isn't affected by
this anti-mutant toxin and all this junk
food and energy drink I think it's
because she isn't a natural mutant like
she was artificially engineered from
Logan's DNA so maybe the gene therapy
doesn't affect artificially enhanced
people and then later when Logan sees
the second half of Gabriella's video we
get a shot of Laura cutting herself
which is actually something Laura does
and the innocence loss series in the
comics we also hear gabriella describes
a new x24 clone as something without a
soul now mangled said that he conceived
x24 as a version of Wolverine from the
darkest time in his life the Weapon X
days so basically everything Logan is
physically without the soul that he
gained from all the relationships that
he's had over his lifetime okay moving
on to Oklahoma City now in an early
version of the story they were going to
go to Vegas but mangled insisted that
the direction of this roadtrip be kind
of linear and not go too far wet however
this was not in Harrah's Casino in New
Orleans where apparently it's illegal
for children to even set foot inside a
casino like legally the governor of the
state would have had to escort Daphne
Kane around the casino premises so even
though most of this movie was shot on
location in camera with practical
effects these shots of Laura simply
walking through the casino had to be
shot on a soundstage using green screen
and upstairs from the hotel room more
and Charles watched the classic Western
film Shane and Shane was another huge
inspiration for the film it features a
lone fighter putting himself in danger
to protect a family from
encroaching on their land which is
exactly what bogan does with a Morrison
family later on and then of course
Shane's iconic ending absolutely
inspired Logan's endings with Laura
repeating these final lines that Shane
gives this teary-eyed dopey looking kid
before limping off to his death maybe I
think it's meant for interpretation also
apparently Patrick Stewart improvised
this line about seeing Shane in a
theater as a young boy like one of the
actors earliest memories was seeing the
film in a cinema in Great Britain and
while this was happening Logan flips
through the transition medical files and
briefly we see bobbies paperwork which
says that his source DNA was Christopher
Bradley that was Dominic monoghan
character from x-men origins aka bold
which is why that we see Bobby have
similar electrical abilities and then
when Logan confronts Laura about her
comic books he says that the stories
were fiction from a self-promoting
in a leotard now to me
this line implies that the person behind
these comics was one of the x-men in my
other video I speculate that this
self-promoting could be Cyclops
who might have put these eaten
coordinates in the comics to lead mutant
refugees to a sanctuary in Canada and
apparently there was a deleted scene
from an earlier version of the story
that involved Logan running into a sort
of underground railroad for mutants run
by another unknown mutant and I think
that could have been Cyclops also as I
mentioned before Liev Schreiber's
Sabretooth was supposed to be in the
story but he was left out because James
Mangold didn't want a bunch of other
mutant cameos I feel like Sabretooth
could have shown up in this bar that
Logan goes to when he realizes Eden
coordinates were from the comics and
moving on to Charles's Mass seizure in
the hotel
notice that when Logan struggles to walk
down the hallway he looks super
restrained and that's because Hugh
Jackman had two crew guides restraining
him with rope but really have you seen
Hugh Jackman of the president needs six
guys and then after they escape the
casino news on the radio compares the
event to the Westchester incident and
that's the thing back east that Pierce
referred to earlier which ended in
Charles's brain being categorized as a
WMD but before Logan turns off the radio
we hear that 600 people were injured and
it took the lives of
and mutants including several of the and
it gets cut off but I assumed she was
gonna say x-men I mean what else was she
going to say cast a Big Bang Theory and
and in my other video I speculated that
those seven could be storm Cyclops
rogue Jean Grey beast Iceman Kitty Pryde
maybe also Nightcrawler and Colossus but
we don't ever know exactly and I'm not
sure we ever will now why doesn't a film
go into this in greater detail the
screenwriter said that an earlier draft
did actually include a flashback to this
Westchester incident a mangled wanted to
keep the story in the present to focus
on the characters not the timeline or
the details and he'd prefer the
Westchester incident to be kind of
mysterious than on the peripherals of
the story and honestly I think the film
is better off for it like we don't need
specific answers to all these questions
we just need to know that there was some
tragic event in the past that caused
Charles and Logan to be super guilty and
then in the meantime nerds like us can
make videos like this and speculate all
kinds of theories on it now if you had
any doubts that this movie is a Western
the one time that we see Charles used
his powers intentionally it's to herd a
bunch of wild horses diam give this man
a lasso and this family dinner scene
again references Charles and Logan's
time at his Institute and apparently an
earlier script contain a line where
Logan is asked if he's married and
Charles says yes but he killed her mmm
but that line was left out because
mangled wanted this to be a purely
picturesque pleasant evening and when
Logan takes Charles upstairs Charles
says this is what life looks like a home
people who love each other a safe place
you should take a moment and feel it and
the reason this line is so important is
for Logan's entire existence his
regeneration and more or less
immortality has made it so that he's
never really been able to appreciate
life and this concept will come back
later
now when Logan and Morrison head off to
the water pump we hear Morrison explain
that the paper corn grown on the
neighboring corporate farms tastes like
but that it's used for a corn syrup
that goes into the energy drinks
everyone's been raving about
so we're Logan this further confirms the
mystery form now I've already talked
about the you know the drill
confrontation in another video but I
just want to point out how again Logan
is really only lit with one source of
lights the headlights on the truck again
the DP is using a single light source to
highlight the physical details on his
arms and chest giving an over
less glamorous shot that makes this a
grittier more grounded scenes and then
this scene back of the house with
Charles and x24 is probably the darkest
most shockingly violent thing I've ever
seen in the superhero film and it's
amazing to see how it all unfolds under
mangled directions it begins with
Charles's emotional confession over his
guilt over the West Chester incident
which plays out like Charles is about to
be executed and he's confessing his
crime but then when X 24 kills every
member of the Morrison family this feels
more like a home invasion slasher film
mangled actually said that he couldn't
believe that he got away with his dark
turn going from a nice family dinner to
this horrific violence
now I mentioned before how mangled
concede X 24 as the darkest version of
Wolverine which really makes him the
fiercest possible enemy for him really
the only thing that we can imagine
killing Wolverine in fact there's some
basis for this in the comics there was a
Wolverine clones named Albert that was a
robotic clone developed by Donald Pierce
and it turns out that the number of
claws that I noticed in the shot in the
first trailer was actually important it
just applied to x24 instead of my
earlier theory that it was jock and fun
while it lasted and then this scene gets
even darker with the box back deaths of
Logan's two soul companions from the
start of his film Charles bleeding out
in the truck and Caliban going out in
style with grenades and mangled said
that he was inspired to kill off a major
character at the end of the second act
by the Cowboys a movie where John Wayne
dies in the middle of the movie which
was a huge deal because everyone was
like wait John Wayne's dead but he'll
are going to do now and then the
surviving kids in the movie had to
figure out things on their own which is
similar to what happens in Logan and
both Charles and Caliban final words are
significant Charles mentions the boat
that they were going to by the Sunseeker
and Caliban turns Pierce's torturous
phrase back on him by saying beware the
light in both cases these men are voting
light imagery in their final moments
signaling that even though this is
obviously the darkest moment of the film
there's light at the end of the tunnel
that will eventually vanquish their
enemies and I think this lost retirement
dream of the Sunseeker
living on the Seas of Charles is what
Logan is referencing when he buries
Charles by this pond breaking down and
saying it's got water and let's talk
about Hugh Jackman's acting here he's
really a
top of his game and sure these small
emotional moments are perfectly
restrained but what really impressed me
the most is his physical transformation
throughout the film Jackman said that he
trained harder for Logan they needed for
any of the other Wolverine movies and
you could definitely see it as the film
goes on his exhaustion and deterioration
intensifies going from merely wounded
and weary and tired to literally every
breath and step he takes being strained
as if they could be his Lac and this is
not easy for an actor to keep track of
most films are shot out of chronological
order so Jackman had to prep for every
scene by carefully adjusting his
physicality so that he wouldn't look any
more or less worn down than the scenes
that would come before or after it when
the scenes were all edited together and
that kind of discipline is definitely
oscar-worthy in my opinion moving on I
like how when Logan wakes up in the
doctor's office the first thing he sees
are these fish mobile things with the
colors yellow in blue the x-men colors
from the comics and considering how much
this version of Logan hates that
depiction of the characters it's almost
like it's saying that he woke up in
x-men hell surrounded by these colors
that he's so tired of seeing and as
Logan and Laura make their last weary
leg of their journey to North Dakota a
lot of people pointed out how their
relationship looks pretty similar to
Joel and Ellie in the game The Last of
Us
now I'm not certain that that was an
inspiration but you could definitely see
the parallel and characters look
especially when Logan passes out in the
car I've also pointed out how the end
game of this story is similar to the
movie children of men which is also set
in a near-future world with a fertility
crisis where a weary hero reluctantly
escorts a special young female really
his last hope through a war zone to a
safe haven bringing harm to himself and
those closest to him okay moving on to
this outpost now it's interesting that
those coordinates from the comic book
actually lead to anything at all right
so even if Eaton doesn't exist as it
does in the comics the fact that they do
lead to this lookout tower implies that
whoever put those numbers in the comics
did indeed have a plan to rescue mutant
refugees so who was it now I go into one
theory my other video but it's also
possible that another group is behind
this rescue operation apparently in the
credits some people are saying that one
of the camera units includes the term
Alpha Flight now I haven't been able to
confirm this but Alpha Flight
is the name of a team of Canadian
superheroes from the Marvel Comics and
then when Richter communicates with
someone over the border with the radio
it's a female voice saying your Asylum
is approved and some people are saying
that could be Emma Frost the White Queen
January Jones played her in first class
before she apparently died leading up to
the events of Days of Future past in the
70s but either way in the comics Emma
Frost becomes an ally and she sets up a
butan Haven which some people are saying
this could be where the kids are going
at the end of the movie but really I'm
not sure if either of those will end up
being the case if there's ever any
people that follows lore and the other
x-23 kids but we'll see okay moving on
during the foot chase in the woods we
get to see these kids in action and a
lot of their powers do seem inspired by
mutants that we've seen before
there was Bobby Bolt who I talked about
earlier and Richter is an actual
character in the comics he can control
seismic energy and I don't know if it's
just because this healing serum is green
but when Logan injects it and goes
berserk it's kind of like he's Popeye
taking the spinach right Hugh Jackman
actually shared a video himself
recording Logan's audio for the sequence
and it's pretty amazing
and then Xander writes arrives to
introduce us of the Logan mentioning his
father Dale Rice who was one of the
scientists Wolverine killed at the
alkali Lake Weapon X facility in Xmen
apocalypse but I loved the decision to
have Logan just kill Rice right in the
middle of him explaining his evil plan
because as we've seen Logan already gets
it the radio collar the newspaper
headline the corn farm and now that Rice
outright confirmed that he's been
flipping anti-mutant gene therapy into
consumer products Logan doesn't need to
hear anything else
this guy's evil when he's got to go now
when X 24 returns a lot of people are
asking how a wooden branch on the tree
was able to impale bogans adamantium
skeleton but from the look at the angle
the branch went through his lower torso
off to the side probably missing in the
adamantium but definitely hitting vital
organs making this wound too much for
Logan to recover from meanwhile the
death of Donald Pierce is a lot creepier
with the kids surrounding him and using
their powers collectively to bury him
and grass and freeze him and shock him
and I think snap his neck but it's
appropriate that baby the ones to kill
him since he's arguably been more of a
greater animated these kids than he
really ever was the Wolverine anyway
back to Logan and next 24 understand how
Logan's adamantium bullet does go
through the brain of Wolverine as he
intended it just kills a different
Wolverine and then cue the waterworks
because as Logan fades away he finally
connects with Laura as father and
daughter with her calling him daddy and
then he says this line so this is what
it feels like now on the surface Logan
is talking about death here the
character has been fatally wounded and
killed over and over but he's never
really been at death's door until now
and this looking away is a whole new
sensation for him but another way to
look at this is Boggan is calling back
Charleston's advice to him earlier and
he's saying this is what life feels like
he has a family who loved him and by
destroying x24 Weapon X Wolverine the
darkest part of his past that he could
never get over he's finally freed
himself of his demons and it could be at
peace he finally just live if only for
just a moment and the final spoken line
of the film is Laura's emotional eulogy
for Logan as they bury him by a pond
maybe connecting them in some way to
Charles's burial site as Laura quotes
Shane's final speech to the kid in the
movie shame a man has to be what he is
Joey can't break the mold there's no
living with the killing there's no going
back right or wrong it's a brand a brand
that sticks so you run on home to your
mother tell her everything's alright
there's no more guns in the valley this
is really perfect for Logan like saying
he was a classic Western hero a loner
with the dark path that he could never
really escape as much as he wanted to we
could never really settle down with the
family he could only deliver them from
harm and then go his separate way
leaving the kid behind crying asking him
to stay but unlike saying this ending is
not at all ambiguous mangle didn't want
a coy ending that lets things up in the
air so this is final no claws popping
out of the ground no pebbles hovering
over the dirt and I mentioned this
before but I love how Logan says
farewell to the character by surrounding
him with kids with body holding a
Wolverine action figure I feel like we
were around this age when we first saw
huge accent play the character and these
kids take us back to this place
emotionally as we say goodbye to the
first of the x-men who started it all
okay that's everything I found
interested in Logan now again there
might have been some little Easter eggs
and timeline stuff I didn't cover but
honestly that's not really what this
movie is all about but I've covered
Logan pretty exhaustively already in my
other trailer breakdowns and my other
explainer video and the Deadpool preview
scene videos so make sure to check all
those out and if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and share this video around
and check out our other videos which
cover all kinds of stuff including a
bunch of Marvel properties and if you
really like this channel you can
contribute to us on patreon thank you so
much to all of our current patrons
because they're awesome
especially you Wilhelmina ebbesson you
can hit me up on Twitter a da Voss with
any thoughts or theories you had about
Logan or you can follow a new rock stars
on Twitter at new rock stars for updates
on our videos okay thanks for watching
bye
[Music]